this video was made possible by
brilliant the first 97 people to sign up
at brilliant org slash Wendover will get
20% off their premium subscription
antarctica is the earth's coldest most
desolate most isolated windiest driest
and southernmost continent all but 2
percent of the landmass is covered in
ice thousands of feet thick human eyes
did not gaze upon the continent until
1820 human feet did not touch Antarctica
until 1895 it is not a place built for
humans but still thousands of people
live there for up to years on end but
how do they get there how do they live
there and how does Antarctica work
Antarctica has thousands of residents
significant infrastructure and a large
transport network and yet it's one of
the very few areas of land on earth not
part of any country seven countries have
made Antarctic claims Chile Argentina
the United Kingdom Norway Australia
France and New Zealand but they are
exactly that claims the only real gauge
of whether a country's territorial claim
is real is if other countries recognize
it and overwhelmingly these claims are
not recognised Australia's claim for
example is only recognized by the United
Kingdom Norway France and New Zealand
countries which clearly have a vested
interest in the recognition of Antarctic
claims for the most part these claims
are ignored one doesn't go through
customs upon arrival in the claims and
certain of them overlap with other
claims the more universally recognized
interpretation is that Antarctica is an
international zone just like outer space
and the ocean Antarctica is considered
part of the common heritage of mankind
meaning that it should be preserved
immaculately for all future generations
forever that's easier said than done the
seminal piece of legislation regulating
the continent is the Antarctic Treaty
just as the Cold War was heating up in
the late 1950s the United States the
Soviet Union and all other countries
with an interest in Antarctica gathered
together to decide how the continent
would be used they emerged with a future
facing treaty that solved most
disputes and issues with the consonant
except for one in its text the tree
specifically says nothing contained in
the present treaty shall be interpreted
as a renunciation by any contracting
party of previously asserted rights of
or claims to territorial sovereignty in
Antarctica essentially they didn't solve
the sovereignty issue because it was too
difficult to solve but they did ban
military presence mining and nuclear
explosions which is helped enormously in
keeping the last continent pristine so
that brings us to today there are no
large-scale commercial operations in
Antarctica
thanks to that treaty the vast majority
of individuals are there for research of
course living and maintaining a base on
the world's most desolate continent it's
hugely expensive but is worth it for the
research that can only be conducted in
Antarctica some individuals are there to
study the continent itself its wildlife
it's geology and its climate but others
use the area to study the entire world
ice cores can be used to track historic
atmospheric carbon levels underground
ponds can be tapped to find ancient
microbial life unique to this area and
ice thickness can be monitored to
understand how sea level rise scientists
even use Antarctica to look at space as
such an isolated place Antarctica has a
very low background radiation and
virtually no light pollution which
allows astronomers to use various
techniques to peer into deep space
scientists are performing groundbreaking
research in Antarctica but how do they
even get there the difficulty in getting
to Antarctica all stems from its weather
the all-time record high at the South
Pole is nine point nine degrees
Fahrenheit the coasts are significantly
warmer where the average summer high is
about 30 degrees Fahrenheit but still
weather above freezing anywhere in
Antarctica is an anomaly as mentioned
this means that there is virtually no
bare ground nearly the entire continent
is covered in thick ice and snow
therefore the only real choice when
building an Antarctic airstrip is
whether to make it on ice or snow one
thing to remember is that antarctica is
a desert the coastal regions where most
of the research bases are do experience
the most no but still then that's a
maximum of 8 inches per year
the South Pole meanwhile only sees two
to three inches of snowfall per year it
doesn't snow much but when it does it
sticks around for centuries
therefore a runway built on ice or snow
is fairly permanent it doesn't get
buried as one might in Canada or Russia
McMurdo stations pegasus field for
example was used for more than 40 years
before it closed in 2016 to be replaced
by the new Phoenix airfield Phoenix
airfield is a compacted snow runway
machines are used to pack the snow until
it's dense enough to support a
fully-loaded 1/2 million pound c-17
wheeled cargo plane but compacted snow
runways have a disadvantage they can
melt during the warmest months of the
summer the snow can warm and soften
enough that is no longer safe to land
wheeled aircraft so that's why there's
the other type of runway blue ice
runways these ice runways are built on
areas of glacial ice where there's no
snow accumulation ice is much more
resilient to warmer temperatures so
these runways can be used year-round
runways on the sea ice are also used
typically at the beginning of the summer
research season in early November until
December when the southern hemisphere
summer begins and the ice starts to
break up whence the coasts are ice-free
cargo ships can also bring supplies into
the major coastal stations and from
there the internal logistics network
gets to work large planes are used to
get as much cargo and as many passengers
to the continent as inexpensively as
possible there are certain airports on
other continents that serve as gateways
to the Antarctic christchurch new
zealand airport for example sends about
100 flights per year and 5,500
passengers to Antarctica and served as
the staging area for the New Zealand
American and Italian Antarctic logistics
operations from there it's only a five
hour flight to McMurdo Station the
largest Antarctic Research Station while
Christchurch is the major Antarctic
gateway flights do also leave from Cape
Town South Africa and Punta Arenas Chile
these larger intercontinental planes
typically land at the major blue ice and
compacted snow runways near the coast
but then many of these passengers and
much of this cargo needs
to get inland the inland research bases
tend to be smaller and there are fewer
of them but they are still significant
the American amundsen-scott South Pole
Station for example has a population of
150 people in the summer and there are
also smaller Italian French Russian
Japanese and German stations away from
the coasts for the American Antarctic
operations McMurdo Station operates as
the logistics hub nearly all cargo and
passengers arrived there on larger cargo
planes or cargo ships from their
passengers in some cargo are transferred
most often onto lockheed el c-130 planes
these prop planes are specifically
designed for Arctic and Antarctic
operations they have retractable skis
that allow them to land on soft non
compacted snow and there are only ten in
existence polar operations often mean
taking off at high altitudes where the
air is thin the amundsen-scott South
Pole Station where the plane often flies
to for example is surprisingly at nine
thousand three hundred feet above sea
level that's even higher than the
highest elevation commercial airport in
the US when the air is thin wings
generate less lift so the speed needed
to takeoff is higher and so in order to
be able to takeoff at higher elevations
this el c-130 plane has rockets to help
speed it up at takeoff thanks to its
skis this plane can operate to those
places like the South Pole station that
don't have compacted snow or blue ice
runways while passengers and some cargo
like fresh food take the quick two-hour
flight from McMurdo Station to the South
Pole there is another way
flights are hugely expensive and the
United States Antarctic program works on
a limited budget so there's an effort
being made to reduce shipping costs
therefore they built a road just like
the runways this road is made from
compacted snow and stretches 995 miles
from Amuro station to the South Pole
using this South Pole traverse the
United States Antarctic program runs
convoys of tractors pulling sleds of
cargo across the ice and snow this trip
takes about 40 days one-way but it still
is significantly cheaper than flights
and can handle cargo too large to fit in
an LC 130 cargo
of course Antarctica is still Antarctica
one of the harshest climates in the
world
whenever a plane leaves from New Zealand
or South Africa or Chile to Antarctica
it's required to take enough fuel to fly
all the way to its destination attempt
landing and fly back to its origin if
landing is not possible planes fail
equipment breaks and weather changes so
Antarctica just isn't a place conducive
to reliability for this reason planes
are prohibited from landing or taking
off in the dark and of course in the
winter in Antarctica it's dark for 24
hours a day
therefore for seven months out of the
year there are no planes no boats no
link at all between Antarctica and the
rest of the world the lack of transport
links during the winter have as much to
do with the cold as the dark at McMurdo
Station where most ships dock on the
coast the winter temperature rarely
rises above zero degrees Fahrenheit
meaning that the coast is blocked with
sea ice and meanwhile at the South Pole
Station
the average July high temperature is
negative 67 degrees Fahrenheit meaning
that if any plane landed there is fuel
would freeze within minutes of course
the large base is like McMurdo Station
which balloons to well over 1,000
residents in the summer need maintenance
over the winter and some science
experiments need to be conducted
year-round so people have to stay in
Antarctica alone in the dark for the
entire winter with no link to the
outside world in recent years there has
been a small number of exceptions to
this lack of flights in winter mostly
due to medical evacuation flights but
for the most part whence the last plane
leaves in February everyone still in
Antarctica is stuck there until the
following November all food fuel and
supplies are stocked there well before
and a small number of people 45 in the
case of the South Pole Station stick
around to keep the bases running in a
sense the people who stay the winter in
Antarctica are even more isolated than
the astronauts on the International
Space Station there are few places
humans can go where they are 7 months
away from medical care from food from
civilization those living and working on
the last continent endure some of the
harshest conditions on this earth but
for the pursuit of science all this
hardship all this work and all this cost
is worth it if you want to live and work
in Antarctica your best shot to get
there is if you're a scientist
in particular a lot of those working
there are astronomers and the best place
to get a basic understanding of
astronomy is brilliant org brilliant
interactive quizzes teach you by
developing your intuition not by rote
memorization with their straightforward
explanations and simple graphics you
really learn a lot quickly I usually
have a blast while taking brilliant
courses they're designed to be
interesting and in this astronomy course
you can learn things like how to measure
the size of the universe
if life on other planets is possible and
how everything on earth is actually made
of old stars by going to brilliant org
slash Wendover you can get started for
free and then by being one of the first
97 people to upgrade to the premium
subscription you will get 20% off